[Music]
on 17th Street in Northwest Washington
is the Corcoran Gallery it's about a
block from the White House and later
this morning we will be talking about a
new display by Leah ben david val is
called propaganda and dreams
photographing in the 1930s the former
Soviet Union and the United States will
take you inside the Corcoran live later
in the program this is c-span's
washington journal our saturday edition
August the 28th coming up in just a
moment Bob Hillman of the Dallas Morning
News will be with us taking your phone
calls and talking to us about the story
that's front page this morning in that
newspaper two zero two six two four
eleven eleven as our liberal line to
zero to six two four one one one five
for conservatives and two zero two seven
three seven six seven three four are
moderate line later in our morning we'll
be talking about the issue of lobbying
and politics with John Moore of the
National Journal he is senior editor of
that publication and later the display
at the Corcoran Gallery propaganda and
dreams by the author of a book and the
person responsible for this display Leah
Ben David Val
but we begin with a story online and
front page in the Dallas Morning News by
Bob Hillman and Lee Hancock the headline
is Reno may seek outsider to review the
siege in Waco which took place six years
ago in 1993 a 51-day standoff that led
to the death of 85 individuals the
Attorney General announced ting that she
will appoint an outside investigator
confirmed yesterday by the Justice
Department Bob Hillman good morning
thanks for being with morning what's
gonna happen next
well I think sometime probably the first
of next week the Attorney General will
explain exactly how the review and
investigation of the new evidence in a
Waco case will go forward it's very
likely that the investigation will be
headed by someone outside the Justice
Department but likely will utilize
investigators of the FBI and perhaps for
the Justice Department as well deeper
into your story a couple of things first
of all congressman Dan Burton is
chairman of the House Government Reform
and oversight committee he's quoted in
your story is saying that Janet Reno and
the Justice Department have lost all
credibility in the eyes of Congress and
in the eyes of the American people I
think particularly on Capitol Hill
there's a lot of suggestions that in
fact the credibility has gone from the
Justice Department particular on this
issue and the FBI and without a doubt
there will be hearings probably both in
the house and in the Senate to
re-examine the whole issue of the siege
at Waco and then you also write on the
issue of military allegations that a
former CIA employee told The Dallas
Morning News on Thursday that he had
heard from several members of a secret
US military unit that they had been
present and actively involved in the
final FBI tear gas assault this has been
reported elsewhere as well can you
explain well this one CIA agent has said
on the record that other military people
who were at Waco members of the
so-called Delta Force were actively
involved in a various aspects of the
final day siege the Justice Department
is investigating this again the Defense
Department has denied that was the case
although they do concede that they were
military people there as observers and
also provided some equipment but they
say that was all within the range of the
law
Bob Hillman is a national affairs
correspondent for the Dallas Morning
News a graduate of the University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign born in
Peoria Illinois you'll be with us for 45
minutes
you can also fax or email us our address
is journal at c-span org the story this
morning is at the Dallas Morning News
website which the address is what Dallas
news.com this morning Hugh Ainsworth has
this piece inside The Washington Times a
follow up on the whole issue of the
Branch Davidians sect it says that the
Branch Davidians once considered a
threat to society until 85 followers
perished in an inferno in 1993 are still
evidence around Waco and the infamous
Mount Carmel enclave on this particular
day 105 degree temperatures last week
there were several car loads of Tours
from the US as well as other countries
including Pakistan and China as they
drove to the compound they walked
quietly around the nearly deserted
acreage often stopping to say a prayer
to snap a few pictures and eventually
visit mrs. Roden who is 56 years old she
lives with a ton in a tiny eight by
eight foot one-room house and she among
other former Branch Davidians want to
claim this area as
their own land I think there's also
moved to build a small chapel on the
site too but apparently there are at
least three factions of the sect that
are at issue here as to who exactly owns
the property and it sits before the
courts I think this is the picture of
Amy Bishop Roden who lives in a wooden
shack near that compound is we get a
call from Dallas City I'm sorry from
Atlantic City New Jersey good morning
yes good morning I'm reading from the
Atlantic City press into where the
headline is Rena valves to get to the
bottom of sea Sh
you know it just behooves me six years
later you know all of a sudden this
comes to light what I see what really
scares me I'm the father of four young
children and what really scares me is
that our government knew there was
little children inside that building and
all of a sudden six years later we're
going to get to the bottom of this
what's happening in this country what's
going on it's so so sad we have become
the most evil empire on the face of the
earth thanks for the call Bob Hillman
well I think it's sometimes just takes a
while to get to the bottom of very
complicated events and surely this was a
complicated event as we indicated
earlier the credibility now the Justice
Department the FBI or have been called
into question and I think we're going to
go through the whole issue again and it
may take several months to do this it
will take several months
how far is Waco from Dallas oh it's
about 60 miles 70 miles our next call
from Salem Virginia on our conservative
line good morning good morning I'm a
first-time caller so I'm a little bit
nervous but I'd like to kind of
reiterate what the previous caller said
to the I think Janet Reno has lost not
only all credibility but I think she's
lost all integrity she when when this
originally happened she promised that
she would she said that she would take
all responsibility for it
and to me that means that in light of
what happened and the the terrible
tragedy she should have resigned I'd
like to know what was when when when
somebody takes responsibility for it and
she said that this is was her Justice
Department and and and the buck stops
here I believe was the word that she
that she used what were the consequences
I mean she still remained on the job
she still head of the Justice Justice
Department she's still the Attorney
General so really she took no
responsibility for what happened
normally when people with integrity
would be faced with this kind of tragedy
they would do the honorable thing and
resign
thanks color response well the Attorney
General in fact did take responsibility
for the outcome at Waco and and gathered
some high marks for that initially she
met with the press this week and was
frustrated she said angry at the turn of
events but she also said she intended to
to stay on as Attorney General she is I
believe the longest Attorney longest
serving Attorney General in the nation's
history now she sent her in her seventh
year and she intends to stay there were
stories earlier this summer that she was
going to step down in September or
October does this have any impact on
those stories it's really hard to tell
my guess is that she'll stay on at least
until the congressional hearings are
through it's really hard to tell what
the eternal events will be here
how's her health she does have
Parkinson's disease but she is she's
doing quite well I think as Attorney
General and reference her health
problems our next caller reading the
Youngstown Vindicator in eastern Ohio
calling from Girard on our conservative
line good morning good morning I'm also
reading the Waco article it says
military defenses role as investigation
begins where did they place that story
in the newspaper it was on the bottom
half of the page front page and it says
notice it says the Attorney General
described herself as very well
twelve and it says I can't I can't wait
to see what defense she's going to use
on Capitol Hill this time I'm wondering
if it'll be the Deaf dumb and blind fire
what fire there was no fire defense or
the one where she starts flopping around
a public place and eventually passing
out to keep from testifying or even the
no one would have died had we not been
there but I think the public is just
stupid enough to believe it was somehow
their fault to them and I had just one
question and that is which is more
credible correct at the fire himself or
Reno thing they've been in there long
enough let's smoke them out thanks for
the call from Gerard Ohio I think one
line of explanation that's already
emerging from the FBI and from the
Justice Department goes along these
lines
they said they may have in fact fired
two pyrotechnic devices tear gas devices
but at a bunker away from the main wood
frame headquarters of David Koresh and
his followers and that they fought fired
these two canisters many hours before
the or several hours before the actual
final assault began and they claim that
they don't believe it had anything to do
with the fire that resulted speaking of
investigations this is an Associated
Press story by Connie Cass it's in The
Washington Post it's also in the
Philadelphia Inquirer and in the New
York Times the headline is that the Ken
Starr investigation issued about 4.2
million dollars in contract work the
story says that 1.5 million was paid to
private investigators another eighty
eight hundred and forty three thousand
dollars for advice on legal and ethical
issues this according to a new
accounting of the five-year
investigation the overall cost forty
million dollars the request for the
investigate investigation put forth by
two Democratic senators byron Dorgan of
North Dakota and Patrick Leahy of
Vermont Senator Leahy says quote there
is no conceivable way to justify these
types of expenditures this is after he
tied up 78 FBI agents assigned to his
office but ken starr's and spokeswoman
Elizabeth Ray says that the
investigation was a monumental effort
that required an unusually number
number of commitments and resources I
think this is another issue that
probably will be reviewed by Congress
when they returned he had many resources
mr. Starr did at his a beckon call from
the FBI and other federal agencies but
also used additional monies to hire a
private investigator or specialized help
to to review some of the evidence there
were a total of 57 contractors including
jury consultants paid a hundred and
forty seven thousand dollars for trial
work and lawyers who made three hundred
and seventy three thousand dollars
representing ken starr's office in court
matters including allegations that the
independent counsel's office illegally
leaked grand jury secrets our next call
is from Fort Myers Florida reading the
news press good morning caller hello
you're on the air yes I'm the article
that I have here's Reno wants Waco truth
no investigation targets FBI role and
Mike my comment and my question to the
reporter is it absolutely astounds me if
Janet Reno I believe if Janet Reno was
in fact a male attorney general she
would be drummed out of office nobody
will call this woman what she is
everybody's always reticent to say well
I don't think that she had any actual
you know it coverup intent I think it's
maybe incompetence we're talking about
the China Gate the everything that this
woman has done has been so crooked it
just absolutely astounds me that nobody
will call her what she is
and that is a political shill for the
President and I don't believe for one
second that she's going to get down to
the bottom of anything she's just going
to reconstruct the cover-up because
Louie free was deep into this at the
time too I'd like your comment well she
does at least today have the confidence
of the President White House press
secretary Lockhart indicated that just
several days ago so I think she's going
to continue to serve from the
International page is this on the
aftermath of the earthquake in Turkey
the damage estimate expected to hit ten
billion dollars a half a million remain
homeless and there are international
implications this is Laura Kings story
The Associated Press the sometimes
prickly nature of Turkey's relations
with the rest the west was apparent
yesterday even as the World Bank had
pledged large-scale aid to Turkey the
government declared that it would rebuff
any aid that came with strings attached
the story goes on to say that the state
minister of Turkey quoted if the
European Union tried to condition a to
such things as improving turkeys human
rights record that aid would be refused
and there is a related story on that
issue this morning in The New York Times
on turkeys relations with Israel which
are apparently getting stronger over the
last few years Israel and Turkey have
built a strategic partnership that has
altered the face of Middle East politics
and Israel is coming to the aid of
Turkey following the the aftermath of
the earthquake and there's a related
story on the other side a Washington
memo piece by by the New York Times
which previews Madeleine Albright's trip
she leaves next week for a two-week tour
that will include a stop in the Middle
East
Damascus Israel and Egypt we'll get a
call from Omaha Nebraska reading the
world herald good morning good morning
I had a this is about Janet Reno our
article was yesterday on that I was
wondering about why they keep using the
term bunkers you know they they call
that swimming pool a bunker they call
the vault that they had off the kitchen
the tornado shelter they call that a
bunker and the other thing was with web
Hubbell wasn't he very much involved in
that and they say they shot it away from
the building to block an escape route
but weren't they trying to get him to
leave and why would you block an escape
route
and I don't think that they can really
have the investigation in DC I think
they need to get it out of DC maybe
they're texas rangers or somebody
because i think the feds just don't seem
to be able to investigate the feds
anymore it's it's like they cover up for
each other they'll hang out Thank You
caller by filming the issue of the Texas
Rangers came up yesterday as well here
in Washington why
that make a difference whether they do
the investigation or a federal agency
well the Texas Rangers are in fact doing
an investigation a new one and it's very
active and I think that you'll find that
they will be cooperating with the not
only with the Justice Department FBI
investigation but also with
investigators on Capitol Hill Tampa
Florida reading The Tribune good morning
good morning good morning gentlemen I
wanted to talk to you about a concern I
have related to what this particular
news event is going to do to what I
consider to be the crazies out there who
took this event as some sort of historic
marker you have your militia groups
there you have your apparently very
dangerous people walking around with
guns who have sort of taken this event
as a some sort of rallying point so many
of us in the minority community are
frequently victims of these kinds of
individuals and their points of view
related to these events I'd like to hear
your thoughts on that well I think it's
quite possible that that the renewed
interest in Waco could also bring with
it you know a resurgence of criticism
and a resurgence of critics and I think
the Justice Department is quite ware of
that possibility Alan Greenspan is in
Jackson Hole Wyoming at an event
sponsored by the Kansas City Federal
Reserve Bank there's a story this
morning below the fold and the
Washington Post the headline Greenspan
sounds a warning and the gist of the
story is that the chairman of the
Federal Reserve Board says that the
rising value of US assets such as stocks
and homes has created what he is calling
new vulnerabilities to large abrupt
declines in asset prices that he thinks
could hurt the American economy comment
on this well I'm I think this is an
issue that mr. Greenspan is trying to
you know highlight in this meeting and
in Wyoming which is an annual meeting
and I guess the market dipped a little
bit but recovered after his remarks
yesterday this is a quote from Alan
Greenspan in the Washington Post to
anticipate a bow
about to burst requires the forecast of
a plunge and prices of assets previously
set by the judgments of millions of
investors many of whom are highly
knowledgeable about the prospects for
the specific companies that make up our
broad stock price indexes follow that
sounds pretty complicated to me we'll
get a call from Buffalo New York good
morning reading the Buffalo News on our
conservative line good morning I'm
reading an article it's just a little
blip on the left-hand section of our
newspaper and it says judge decides to
allow vouchers at Cleveland and I think
that should be talked about a little bit
this morning how he reneged although
he's keeping the same policy he's
allowing the children to go to school
this year because the 11 point two
million dollar budget already went
through for the vouchers and that's a
good decision and another little dip lip
in our paper of course our papers are
very liberal paper on page a 9 on the in
the bottom left-hand corner it says
Clinton's leniency towards militants has
little support and that's where the
terrace he wanted to release from jail
and it just was a failure for him and
they just give it a three little
paragraph in our paper and I want that
discussed about the berth vouchers and
how the judge just turned back on his
decision color before we get an answer
from our guest Bob Hillman of the Dallas
Morning News have you been following the
situation in Cleveland the school
district there yes I have and you know I
am a conservative but I'm not a radical
right conservative and I think vouchers
are very important for these children I
was sent to a private school when I was
younger and I was like a year ahead of
the high school students when I went
into a public school and they do have
better teachers and better discipline my
my daughter teaches school and a public
school she teaches high school and
there's no respect to the teacher and
it's hard to teach Thanks thank you for
the call Bob Hillman we had a couple of
faxes on this yesterday we talked about
the the issue of education and the
federal responsibilities when it comes
to school districts around the country
george w bush's governor brother Jeb
Bush in Florida was
successful in getting vouchers for
Florida school districts other states
including Pennsylvania not quite so
successful how does that issue translate
into what you've been following which is
presidential politics in governor Bush
of Texas well it's an issue that that is
on a campaign trail particularly in this
primary season that we're entering now
and you know the governor Bush does
favor the favorit vouchers but we don't
have them yet in in in Texas and for
those who are not following the story
what is a school voucher whether it
allows monies to be used or state monies
to be used at private to private schools
essentially for elementary and secondary
education governor Bush was in Atlanta
yesterday earlier in the week he was in
North Carolina next week he is back in
Iowa and in California giving a speech
on education the story in The Washington
Post from Atlanta says that the governor
yesterday backed what he is calling
reasonable curbs on guns he says that he
would allow support closing the loophole
that would allow unlicensed dealers to
sell guns at gun shows without
background checks for purchases provided
governor Bush said the new background
checks could be done instantaneously
Democrats as you know have been
insisting on a three day waiting period
in order to complete the FBI background
check I think this is another issue that
perhaps even will resonate more than
school vouchers in some parts of the
country I think after the incidents at
Littleton and after the other instances
around the country where we've had we've
had shootings there's a perhaps a change
in public opinion on on guns and the
availability of guns as you know in
Texas governor Bush approved legislation
signed legislation that allows Texans
after they're licensed and trained to
carry concealed weapons he's done some
other things too he generally favors you
know the right to bear arms and but he
does specifically have somebody calls
reasonable things that he has back
raising the age from 18 to 21 to buy a
handgun the instantaneous check at gun
shows and things like that he also
raised about a million dollars over the
last three days in a number of campaign
fundraisers as of the end of June the
bush 2000 campaign had collected about
37 million dollars
how much they have now now we really
don't know but clearly it's much more
than that I suspect much more than forty
million at this at this stage he was in
Charleston South Carolina midweek and he
was asked a question about the
Confederate flag which flies over the
State Capitol I think it still flies
over the State Capitol in Charleston the
story from the Dallas Morning News said
that he would not get involved in the
flag flap yeah he views it as a as a
state issue and I think this is good
politics as well too to stay out of the
controversy and in fact the story
answers my question South Carolina is
the only former Confederate state to fly
the flag above its Capitol it has been
raised daily since 1962 to commemorate
the centennial of the Civil War there
have been several attempts to remove the
Confederate flag those attempts have
failed
we'll get another call from Palm Springs
Florida on our liberal line reading the
Desert Sun good morning good morning
i-i-i-i thank you very much for your
program it's a wonderful program you
know I love when all these Republicans
calling and they're all belly aching
about this and that but I know you hear
any of them calling and talk about Mike
foster the governor from Louisiana who
pleaded guilty to taking over a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars from the Ku
Klux Klan and only got fined twenty
thousand dollars now that's what's the
matter with America thank you for very
much for your program thank you for the
call
Pittsfield Massachusetts reading the
Berkshire Eagle good morning on our
moderate line hello I'd like I'd like to
make the point that people seem to be
forgetting that this incident followed
the killing of four of our police police
people that were involved in the you
time at Waco yes and seems to me that
fact that they were there to arrest her
or bring bring to justice and it was
selling guns and maintain a large group
of crazies needs to needs to be
investigated the other way
I think the breaking of the law of
killing killing four police officers
while they were doing a job there's not
being talked about appreciate the call
Bob Hillman well as we must remember the
the siege at Waco began with an
ill-fated raid by the agents of ATF
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms and that
whole raid was investigated as well by
an independent panel of Treasury and a
report was issued on that and changes
were made knowing the top personality F
but also in a way they do do their rates
our conversation this morning is with
Robert Hillman who is a national affairs
correspondent for the Dallas Morning
News has been with that publication for
how many years about 15 years and has
covered a number of stories including
the Oklahoma City bombing trial in
Denver Colorado he joins us for another
20 minutes later this morning we'll be
talking about the issue of lobbying here
in Washington just how much money is
being spent by those trying to influence
the process here in this town and later
we'll take you to the Corcoran Gallery
there's this story below the fold in the
Philadelphia Inquirer by the Washington
bureau reporter Chris Maddox looking at
senator Torricelli of New Jersey he is a
freshman former House member described
as compact intense and extremely
articulate has always been something of
a lightning rod in Washington in the
house he established himself as a
flamboyant presence whose politics were
times unpredictable and who savored the
spotlight whether the attention that got
him was favorable or not the 48 year old
Inglewood lawyer has continued in that
vein in the Senate employing his sharp
tongue to defend President Clinton
during his own impeachment trial and
using his notable fundraising skills to
bolster his reputation among colleagues
you follow much of Senator Torricelli
not really buddy am familiar familiar a
little bit with him I think he's quite a
tough partisan will get a call from
Charleston Rhode Island reading the New
York Times good morning caller yes good
morning from Rhode Island good morning
I'm calling about the article that with
the yesterday's New York Times about
Reno is myth credibility heating up for
wake up I believe that this is a
to cover up their thing that was going
on with China gate that fellow Riley was
working hard for the last two weeks
trying to get somebody to investigate
China gate and I think that this is a
that they have got together Clinton
people in the White House to try to hold
people away from asking about the money
that they got from the Chinese 496 and I
think Janet Reno was going along with
why for six years as she coming up with
this Waco when when that's all done and
gone and here we've got China and the
money coming from it to elect Clinton
and gore in 96 and they are covering
Thank You caller Bob he'll step back for
a moment the news conference that that
essentially broke this story her regular
weekly meeting with reporters on
Thursday did you have any indication
that the Attorney General was going to
announce that she found out what the FBI
allegedly was involved in doing six
years ago well late the night before the
FBI had issued its own statement and it
indicated that they and the Justice
Department would be conducting an
investigation so we had some indication
of that already
how did Janet Reno find out about this
and when did she find out about it as I
understand from her age he she learned
of early in a week essentially from
newspaper reports we got a call from is
a Demarest Georgia reading the Atlanta
journal-constitution hello good morning
good morning go ahead call her okay
I was just wanting to talk about I read
the Atlanta Constitution in Journal and
the situation in Waco and Janet Reno and
I really think they're being unfair to
Janet Reno I think there are a lot of
things that might have been done that
she wasn't even aware of and all I have
heard was you know putting Janet Reno
down and and she's the only one that's
carrying the blame and I understand
that you know she said that she would
carry the blame and I admire her for
that but I don't think she should be the
only one to do that because I think that
probably she was unaware of a lot of
things that went on and I just wanted to
you know to state that thanks color I
wanted to say another thing about gun
control sure okay and I understand that
there are a lot of guns around and I
don't think I no gun for the problems
initially I also think that automobiles
and drunk drivers other problem and I
don't think that you should pinpoint it
on just banning guns because people that
most of the people that use guns use
them legally and use them right you know
but there are the few that get out of
hand and I think the press is really
responsible for a lot of what is
happening because they get exposed so
much and a lot of these people that is
what they want to get exposed teenagers
and Psychopaths are they're gonna do
things like this to bring themselves to
attention appreciate the call we'll get
a response well no not really how to
respond other than the violence is a
problem in this country guns are a
problem in this country and you know
over our history we've wrestled with how
best to deal with it and we continue to
do that take a look at some of the
headlines from the morning newspapers
beginning with the New York Times the 13
year end of the MIR Space Station is the
front page cover photo from CNN
yesterday as the Russian space station
ends its operation there's also this
story by Tim O'Brien the story says a
powerful Russian industrialist whose
Empire is under investigation in the
money laundering inquiry at the bank of
New York yesterday confirm that a large
part of the billions of dollars moved
through the bank was controlled by
Russian officials protecting their
fortunes by shipping their money abroad
before the Russian markets collapsed
last year a story that his resonating
over the last few days and it's the
front page this morning the New York
Times there's also this story front page
of the Washington Times a story that we
have been talking about the Waco review
and the Defense Department doubting the
role of the Delta Force which was
allegedly involved in the final hours of
the the Waco invested the Waco bombing
the Nok bombings but the situation in
Waco which resulted in the death of 85
individuals six years ago and then the
Baltimore Sun has a look at the the
mayoral debate there is a race for mayor
in a number of cities including
Baltimore the primary scheduled for
September the 14th will continue with
your calls next is Kansas City Missouri
on our liberal line reading the New York
Times online good morning good morning
yes I'm just disturbed at the mythology
that seems to have arisen about David
Koresh as just a good Christian man out
there in Waco having a good Christian
organization the man did order his
people to kill policemen and he was
having sex with little girls and his
followers were given and these little
girls over to him for their wives and
he's not a martyr and he is the one
ultimately responsible for the fire and
the deaths
it was just like Jonestown there was not
going to be any other conclusion they
were gonna go out in a blaze of glory no
matter what and I don't think Janet Reno
has any blame or responsibility for this
matter I just feel that a lot of
crackpots of all of a sudden made David
Koresh into some sort of a martyr just
because well I think because the word
Christian was attached to his
organization I think if they've been
black black Muslims or whatever they
might have turned out totally different
they let him have two months to let the
children go and to come to some sort of
a conclusion but he was not a martyr and
I guess that's my main point I'm
disturbed but the mythology that's risen
up about David Koresh and there's plenty
of other people like him out there World
Church of the Creator Matt Hale just
because they have the word Christian or
Christ on there they give him a break
and they let him go on and on and on and
until something horrible happens back to
my comment thank you well that's one
view and I think we should you know
respect that but there are many other
views too about mr. Koresh his followers
the Branch Davidians how the siege began
how it went on for so long and how it
ended it's it's the very complicated man
this is a deeper into the story that I
mentioned earlier from The Washington
Times in the final hours of the siege in
Waco Texas a Defense Department official
who asked not to be identified cast
doubt on the credibility of an ex CIA
employee who told The Dallas Morning
News that 10 Delta Force commandos
actively participated in the FBI raid
further into the story that same
officials said the bottom line is that's
the absolute truth we were not involved
operationally and we did not provide CS
gas I think these are the issues that
are going to come out in this inquiry
and that are going to come out and the
inquiry on Capitol Hill - and that I'm
sure that the military people will be
called to testify and I'm sure various
other people will - and the various
credibility's will be judged at the time
investigations that we will be covering
on this network our next call is from
the capital of Texas Austin reading the
investor's business daily on our
conservative line good morning caller
I'd like to point out an article I was
reading in yesterday's investor's
business daily and talked about another
Panama Canal giveaway this is where I
agree with the caller for him I think
Rhode Island a few back who said this is
just a diversion from what's going off
the Chinese they think there was a deal
set up with this company called
Hutchinson that primarily by the
People's Republic army and China and
they're basically taken over I was
stationed in Panama I was in the Navy
and basically they're given these rights
to these bases away from now on the deal
that President Carter did was there
enough but what Clinton's done through
his payments from the Chinese for his
campaign is allowing them to we have to
go to them now to get permission to
cross through the canal are US warships
although big carriers can't fit through
there anyway but this is a real travesty
and I wonder how come the main press
other than a few things like investor's
business daily isn't covering this I
think this is horrible even though I had
to smell living here in Austin the smell
of dead babies these people who they
think it's okay for the government to
can kill babies and get their Janet Reno
should be held responsible for that -
thanks thank you
well this caller is an issue that
another one raised as well and and that
that somehow this new investigation and
new evidence here at Waco is a diversion
to distract the Clinton administration
the Justice Department or something else
a taste don't we that's the case so
these events are driven by by other
events and I can't believe that the
Attorney General was expecting to deal
with them this week or next week into
the collar in Austin and we've had a
number of calls on the whole issue of
the Panama Canal and in part because of
your interest and also the upcoming
transfer on December the 31st we will be
traveling to the Panama Canal region
this fall and putting together a rather
extensive series of programs looking at
the history of the canal why it was
built why the United States took it over
from the French during the turn of the
century the role of Teddy Roosevelt
president of the United States at the
time responsible a key player in the
building of the canal also moving
forward with the treaty that was signed
in 1978 by President Carter and then the
transfer that will take place in what it
means for the United States and the rest
of the world those issues being
addressed in a series this fall that we
will be covering here on c-span so we
appreciate your your call on that thanks
for telling us about the investor
business daily story you will use that
as we prepare for the program we'll get
a call from Tulsa Oklahoma reading the
Tulsa world good morning how are you
today we're doing fine how are you I'm
all right and I'm calling for the
purpose I am so sick and tired of all of
these extreme right-wing cooks trying to
pin down everything on President Carter
they gave Ronald Reagan of free rats
Ronald Reagan a man who sold arms to the
enemy violated the 1979 United States
embargo against Iran the u.s. arms
export missions Act this rape saline
water is back in 1952 they never wanted
anyone to investigate Ronald Reagan yet
they call me and all the dogs on Clinton
every little thing he does every little
thing that it is allege that he does
they pins a rap on Clinton it's crazy
it's nuts these right-wingers are insane
they're trying to take over the country
Clinton is a good president I'm proud of
the president certainly he's a more
decent person in Ronald Reagan who in my
opinion had more
who was the most corrupt president in
the history of the country who is
constantly being covered up by the right
wing they never wanted anyone to
investigate Ronald Reagan but a fellow
Republican yet they turn it loose the
dogs on Clinton this is sick can't you
see it and Thank You caller by the way
the president yesterday at Martha's
Vineyard among his foursome Prince
Andrew yes and I heard that the game got
rained out as it were in the later holes
they played golf Frank Rich who is a
frequent guest on this network has a
piece on the op-ed page of the new york
times looking at texas governor george w
bush a couple of excerpts from what he
wrote this morning a bump in the road a
setback a boon to his primary opponents
poles' the people who dourly predicted
dark consequences from george w bush's
mishandling of the snort gate were the
same geniuses who predicted bill
clinton's imminent demise 20 months ago
after the avalanche of india nation
incident insinuations that the texas
governor might have used cocaine and is
now engaged in the cover-up mr. Bush is
in fact in the words of his campaign
advisor Ralph Reed better off than he
was before the firestorm started far
from bungling his first encounter with
adversity the front-runner handled it
like a master given the choice between
scolds and scams the American people
opted for scams the more the media pile
on a politician over a private scene
privates in let alone a sin for which
there is no evidence or accusations
despite major investigations are the
Washington Post and The Wall Street
Journal the more the public will rally
around the targeted candidate well
perhaps there is some truth to this
because I think that on issues like this
often the media get maligned for making
the inquiry asking the questions and
essentially doing our job which is our
job Tim Rowland and the Philadelphia
Inquirer has this look at george w bush
he says that the texas governor has
clearly hit a winner with the slogan
compassionate conservativism having a
head like john d rockefeller with a
heart like Johnny Appleseed's is a
hybrid that obviously resonates with the
public we'll get a call from Atlanta
Georgia on our liberal line reading an
article from USA Today good morning
good morning c-span I'm actually a
libertarian so I just picked one okay
but I'm reading an article in USA Today
about the the Russian IMF money being
laundered through New York Bank front
page I think I've read an excerpt let me
show it to you against front page story
just above the fold in the New York
Times okay go ahead it's really amazing
now our government has given billions
and billions of dollars to this of my
money to this IMF fund and now we found
out that as much as fifteen billion
dollars has gone down a corrupt hole and
is coming back to America to be
laundered through our banks and the
point I want to make that our government
cannot and this administration cannot
give sign a bill to give me a 1% tax cut
phased in over ten years while at the
same time my money is being freely given
to corrupt administrations around the
world thanks caller there's also this
sidebar piece I'll open it up it is what
makes a nation turn corrupt taking a
look at what the situation is like in
the former Soviet Union also in
Indonesia
I think perhaps this IMF loan and the
money laundering investigation that's
underway now in reference to it and the
Russians may resonate as well in the
presidential campaign
among other things Vice President Al
Gore has been the administration's point
person with the with the Russian
administration and is likely to find
himself having to answer some questions
about the turn of events our next call
on our conservative line from Wisconsin
and you'll have to help me with the name
of your town it's a CEO and you're
reading what publication I was reading
earlier this week the Capitol Hill blue
online and what is that that is a online
publication dealing with political
issues who publishes it I don't know I
just get it online I don't have it in
print form I've never heard of it I
don't like it's a very good
I have not oh well what they were
talking about is the fact that no trow
Trulock was forced out of the Energy
Department at the request of President
Clinton and this has happened the exact
day that Waco broken in the papers this
has gotten absolutely no attention
Waco has so when we're saying that
things are being covered up what we are
saying is that the stories that really
deserve to be looked into are not if you
go back to - chuckle Abela he was hired
by Janet Reno
he gave her a report just coinciding
with what Louis Freeh says about Chinese
money money situation and and he was
forced out they don't want to see what's
going on with this administration and
you know when I'm being called a
right-wing nut and somebody is going
after President Reagan this is the most
corrupt administration that this country
has ever experienced and we really want
to get get it over an and pasta thank
you
comment well I think there has been the
considerable coverage of the the Energy
Department referenced the investigation
of possible espionage and in fact with
the with with the retirement or
dismissal of the Energy Department
official that she referred to we'll take
one more call this is just another story
that some viewers might find of interest
its front page below the fold of The
Washington Times the head of AOL Steve
Case is buying Mary wood estate if
you're not familiar with that it was the
childhood home of Jacqueline Onassis
Kennedy Jacqueline Kennedy Onassis it
was built in 1920 and it was purchased
at a price of seventeen and a half
million dollars a seven-bedroom home on
seven acres overlooking the potomac
river our last call for Bob Hillman of
the Dallas Morning News is read in
California good morning morning just a
slight issue to raise the word we're
talking about the you know the issue
with the the Russian money laundering
you know a brief history lesson in our
in
growth as a nation we can look back at
our turn-of-the-century and the
industrial complex we see a great deal
of corruption over a number of years
with our own growth and yet we sit back
judgmentally you know 6070 years later
and it's like living in a glass house
and in throwing stones and I just I just
wonder what your comments would be on
that thank you well I think it's gonna
be an investigation that's gonna go on
for some time and this likely to have a
few surprises our guests for the last 45
minutes has been Bob Hillman of the
Dallas Morning News prior to that he
worked for the Chicago sun-times he
covers national affairs politics and the
white house and we thank you very much
for getting up on a Saturday morning and
explain your front-page story this
morning dealing with the investigation
that Janet Reno is now calling for into
the Waco Siege and the role of the CIA
and the FBI allegedly in that 51 day
raid thank you thanks for being with us
we're gonna take a short break and come
back and talk about the issue of money
politics and lobbying here in Washington
DC it's East bends Washington journal
for Saturday the 28th of August campaign
2000s the race for the Pres